Điều bản đamu sê hôm đà chính hãng, bản hoàn toàn của thị tháng ra chương trình này.
Tương ngày 1 tháng từ năm nay ngàn không trăm 20 xấu,
chương trình thăm ra khảo sáp Rinh quả liên tay được hòn đà chịp thải trên toàn quốc.
Dễn ra đến hết năm nay ngàn không trăm 20 xấu với các đời quay thường được tổ chức hàng tháng 20 xấu.
Chỉ cần là 1 khảo sách nắng của hôm đà Việt Nam,
bản có cơ hội nhận giải gật bệnh quyền là chức sêng,
hôm đà viên bản cao cấp và nhiều dại thường hàng tháng giải chị như ai phát,
xam xuống gà là xí hoặc a phố ổng và hàng chăm phần qua hấp dẫn khác.
Em biết khoảng 2 đến 3 phút đau ngốc ý kên,
bản vừa có cơ hội quay thường đến phần qua giải chị.
Vừa nhận thiên một nơi để mai hòn đà ph lớn.